leverage is critical you know i get so
much done
because i don't just get it done i know
the outcome i know the purpose
and i look for leverage leverage is
different than delegation
what's problem with delegation
delegation is you have all that needs to
be done so you give it to someone else
and you tell them needs to be done and
when they don't do it you're pissed off
leverage says i can move the biggest
boulder in the world
with a little bit of effort if i get
something i can do it with
but i'm still part of it so leverages if
i'm gonna leverage something here with
tom
i'm gonna make sure tom understands the
what the outcome i wanna make sure tom
understands the
the purpose the why and the action but i
might say to tom if you can get this
done
without this action or better action go
for it baby
and i want to talk to you on this date
and we got to promise and we're going to
check in before it's needed
so there's no surprises if you're having
problems tom come back to me because
we're partners on this
that i call leverage